do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has helped
develop all lot of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this
course to access the free life-changing
training
now between me and you is what you
follow a religion also I also follow
religion that's saying yeah and and
check any
statistics check in statistics yeah
there's no Prophet that came to England
and there are hundreds of thousands of
people that come to Islam British
English woman they don't need the
prophet we have we have mons we have
monks they don't even see woman no
problem and then they rap
me I believe that they have good
intentions but they're following the
wrong way their intentions are good
because let me tell you why because in
the Quran
I have I I chose to I read the Bible I
read Christianity I looked into Islam I
looked into Judaism I looked into sism
and Hinduism three years I spent and
then I realized the Quran is the only
one that is the true why because I have
evidence I have evidence that this Quran
is the truth very simple I have
prophecies I have historical Miracles
not only that Allah says in the Quran if
you think this is not from Allah bring
something like it make something like
this Allah says in the Quran we have you
have so many books like that make like
this I will leave Islam
today if you bring a single verse like
this I'll leave Islam Today have so
many they believe they believe we
believe but the Bible is corrupted that
doesn't mean that you know why because
we have evidence I bring me a Christian
here he would say to you my Bible is
changed me Muslim I will never say that
bring me a Christian go get me a
Christian he will accept now I will
prove to him no I know but I'm saying a
CHR Christian will come and say to me my
Bible is changed not one Muslim will
come and say the Quran is changed the
Quran is the same from the time of the
Prophet till now and there's evidence is
in this Quran how how do you very simple
for example very simple it's not the
same Arabic you know that what you mean
Arabic that they written Quran from the
beginning it's not the same no it's only
has the dots the dots have been changed
it doesn't have the dots no I know but
still thean when you add the dot yes so
you are you speak Arabic right no I
don't I can read it by you know that if
you the meaning no no no no no you can't
it can't it can't it can't it can't it
can't who may be Muslim let me tell you
I looked into before I believed in God
like you but I said to myself I don't
believe in religion just like you I said
religion is story lies the stories and
lies then I said I have to read now one
second brother you ask me a question so
I looked into the Quran I read the Bible
I read the Old Testament I looked at
Hinduism I looked at the Sikhism I did
my research for three years and the only
truth that I came to was the Quran
because it hasn't been changed number
one it hasn't been changed number one it
hasn't been changed and he has Miracles
I can prove to
you open
challenge how do you know
who was it for me yeah how do you know
who wrote This Book very no problem no
problem no problem Allah says in the
Quran very it's good good question good
question give me another reference is
I'm saying sorry I'm saying I don't
accept this book I every time I ask you
question no no no no no I'll give you
reference I'll give you I'll give you
reference outside outside I'm going to
go to it says that the Earth is like
flat no it doesn't it says we've spread
the Earth is the earth one is it flat or
round
here no no no is this is this round or
flat one second look look one second is
the road straight or
bent this is B geographically no no no
no on what level no no I know that no no
no look it's simple not like this is it
like this or like
this I know I no from
here
slightly no problem no problem but we do
know that it is not absolutely straight
but it's straight enough for us to
walk would you agree good now when Allah
says he spread the Earth he spread the
earth look all the way there I know a
slight Bend but I can walk straight I
don't fall over but how do you know that
the way that you transl to yourself is
completely different no no no no no no
no Allah look to us there is no way
Allah says the Earth is flat the Earth
what Allah says is we spread the earth
now know do you know that Allah meant
that what you saying what you mean what
else could he mean if he saying we we've
made the Earth something for you to walk
on no he didn't say it's flat it says we
spread the earth now you ask me a
question I'll go to Surah room Allah
says in the Quran
room outside outside hear me out outside
I'm giving you a reference and I'm going
to prove it outside non-muslims I'm
going to give you non Muslims Allah says
in the Quran the Romans this is history
in history Allah says the Romans have
def defeated the Persians you're from
Iran yeah okay good ask any historian
yeah the Romans have defeated the
Persians do you know this historical
fact one time that one time yes do you
know this good but
before good good okay the Roman have
defeated the Persians you know this yeah
okay good Allah says in the Quran
something very interesting he says and
after the defeat the Romans are going to
come back and defeat the Persians now
let's put this into context if I say to
you today Americans have defeated the
the congales in Africa and then I say
America superpower yes superpower Amica
America destroyed the people in Congo
and then I say in four years time
the conges people are going to take over
America you cannot say that but you can
say that for Iran some some country like
Iran I could say no no Iran is still
strong not no I'm giving a really weak
country like I'm saying milit militarily
was not weak at that time Persia was not
okay I'll give you an example okay no
problem this park you know this park
these people here imagine America they
beat us and then I say we are going to
beat America in four years time is that
a big
claim yeah is a b claim is it a risky
claim yeah it is good yeah but not for
something like Roman Empire and Persian
Empire because both were extremely
strong no you know why because if you
read Edward Gibbon who's A non-muslim in
his book of the Roman Empire Edward
Gibbon he said when the Persians
defeated the Romans Rome was on the
Brinks of collapse yeah it me Rome is
nearly finished not superpower they got
defeated so bad now check this out and
answer my question how is it that Allah
in the Quran says after the defeat the
Romans are going to come back and beat
the Persians that is the big claim
massive claim risky claim now what
happened after 3 to seven years Edward
Gibbons non-muslim not the Quran put the
Quran to a side non-muslim historians
say how is it possible Edward Gibbon
said that the Romans came back and
defeated the Persians I'll tell you how
tell me how okay tell me how sorry Sal
who's
Sal Salman far Salman far okay he used
to be the prime minister at that time do
you know that Salman he used to be prime
minister Persian Empire the sahaba Sal
Al no I don't know I know he was he was
taken as a slave no he was taken as a
slave okay the Empire kick him out and
he refused the Muslim people okay that's
how it started so he knew that what's
going to happen at least he knew one
second one second one second you talk
about Al he was a slave and then for
example he went on a journey knowing
that the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is going to come so you're telling
me that is the answer to this claim
really brother
really really brother brother you do MMA
yeah you're fighter I I can see from
your ears yeah I can see from your
biceps yeah brother listen to me you are
a fighter yeah imagine there is somebody
child and I say this boy is going to
knock you out you
say so now I'm asking you a question
please answer me how did Allah how did
the prophet Muhammad okay you don't
believe from Allah how did the prophet
Muhammad know this fact and how it's
risky for the prophet Muhammad to say
the Romans are going to beat the
Persians it's a risky claim and and it
doesn't I can claim that no you can't no
you can't I say claim it tell me give me
answer five times in in five years yes
Russia going beat no one sec one second
Russia is a
superpower Russia is a superpower
brother listen to what I'm saying to you
listen to what I'm saying brother no no
listen to me no Romans look I'm giving
you non-muslim sources not a Muslim
Edward Gibbons is a historian yeah now
he's saying the Roman Empire was on the
Brinks of
collapse there is no Empire they were so
badly defeated now why would brother
listen to me please if they got defeated
so bad the prophet Muhammad one second
if the prophet Muhammad was not a true
person he would say the Persians beat
the Romans and the Persians are always
going to win he says the opposite why
would he take that risk because if it
was proven wrong that means he's not a
prophet and guess what the real thing
happened I can give you 20 examples like
this this is just one I can give you 20
examples the prophet Muhammad when you
talking about Sal Al yeah in the Battle
of kandak one second in the Battle of
kandak Salman Al gave the idea to do
trenches good the prophet Muhammad came
and there was a rock that they couldn't
Smash and he said allahar he smashed he
said Allah has given me sham think and
then he smashed and and said
Yen how does he know one second the look
listen the mus were coming to kill them
the maafin were inside them the Jews
have backstabbed them they were in the
verse of on the verge of being killed
and the prophet said smash Allah has
given me Smash Allah has given me y
question one second one second how did
the prophet Muhammad if we are about to
be killed imagine they are coming to
kill us and I say Brothers don't worry
Allah has given us America Allah has
given us Russia Allah has given us China
you're going to say brother are you okay
they're about to kill us so tell me how
did he know let me tell you something
firstly I believe you know what you
believe I you Muslim aldah so why I'm
argu with you brother why I'm argu with
you all this time ask a question you
Muslim why you you're on the wrong side
come here you MMA fight the thing is
come here the thing is no no brother
thing is if I ask a question my question
maybe I know the answer but I want I'm
want
clarify me so history you know is not
100% proven so whoever
wins we never know what happened 2000
years ago no no no we do we do we do Ed
I tell you I'll tell you look go and get
his book Edward Gibbons when it comes to
the he's an expert on Roman history
listen to me brother this is a
non-muslim Muslim non-muslim even non
Muslim they can make brother brother
brother brother brother brother brother
a brother what you see okay do you see
your conscious sorry do you see your
conscious no but I feel it show me I
feel do you see do you see do you see
wind no but that's my point that's my
point you said I see what I believe
brother one second you said I see what I
believe do you see your brain you mean
you're conscious I see I I don't mean I
see it I know I know what I believe I I
have so I'm asking you a question how
did how did you're on my side don't go
anywhere I'm asking you how did how did
the prophet know when it came to the
Romans are going to be defeated how did
the prophet know that they're going to
take over sham Yemen and Iraq how how he
did brother he said it tell me how did
they know the prophet muhamad said one
second the prophet Muhammad
said no there's no compion religion so
why why Islam attacked like
one second conquering listen babba
conquering is separate Force very simple
if I come you kill children you kill
show me whenever listen show me whenever
listen the Quran that say kill children
show me we just bring
the listen to me my brother my brother
listen to me my brother there's three
things that the Islam gives number one
come and join Islam you say no you pay
jiz no Jia we will fight you but we will
fight the men why because we want to
spread Islam to the people but I'm not
allowed to force you to accept Islam
it's kurish arish you said all this time
you're on the wrong side brother what
you doing side thing is you
know I can't say okay I believe it and I
have no idea why is that you believe
attacking by Muslims of Iran was
wrong then why did why did Iran attack
GRE and why did Iran attack Africa I'm
not saying the nature is like this lion
comes
eats baby thing like yeah I I I don't
have anything any problem with them but
the thing that I'm that I have problem
is you saying that our religion is a
religion of Peace which no I never said
that brother one when did I say religion
Rel brother our religion when brother
what's your name y may Allah bless you
brother yeah I'm just a big passionate
yeah brother listen brother y we don't
say my religion is I throw roses if you
come to fight me bro I'm going to fight
you we're not fighting you no no if you
want to fight me I got MMA fighter here
I got I got fight wait a second wait a
second do you know the history between
Persia and the Arabs who started the war
yeah who started the
wared No you're saying Islam attacked
the the Muslims attacked Persia AR
didn't have any civilization okay do you
know do you know that Omar be sorry om
Omar may Allah be pleased with him he
said I wish there was a wall of fire
between us and the Persians yeah because
Persia was a hostile power Persia was a
colonizing power do you know Persia had
colonized parts of Yemen and the
Persians had sent two people to go in
arrest the prophet peace be upon him yes
so the Persians were aggressiv not only
that they killed the message they killed
the the the one who sent the message
they executed him and that's you have to
keep this in
mind wait wait a minute no wrong side
he's on our
side have my brothers as
well Im is thicker than blood
you are our
brother come to Islam
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah government I don't like
the government
isob you're my brother I want you I want
the best for you from my understanding
it was very clear Persia had colonized
Yemen Yemen was Arab land and from the
uh Persian persianized colonized Yemen
to the second one second two people this
is okay wait if I'm going to give you a
reference are you going to say I'm I'm
wrong and you're right or are you going
to agree to references because a second
ago you said we can't trust historians
you said that of course because now wait
wait wait wait one second so you want a
reference and you're saying we can't
trust okay first first this two
ambassadors went from Yemen Persian
ambassadors they came to the prophet and
they came for what to arrest him because
they were Persian ambassadors and they
were upset for whatever reason they were
sent so Persia was a colonizing power
Persia was an advancing power Persia sto
the
arish I don't like is going to look at
this conversation and think that
actually just
Muslim follow him I follow
him if I have son I call him Sal the
abans my name is Ali why do the Muslims
is Ali why you got my name and the
Propet said not fight the abans unless
they fight you this is a this is a
narration yeah do not fight the Turks
unless they fight you Persia was an
aggressive power do you know the
atrocities committed by the Persian
Empire what unheard of in the ancient
world do you know about this the Persian
Empire was one of the most vicious
empires in human history do you know
this what about Egypt you you talking
about killing children Egypt you talking
about killing children wait one second
do you know the amount of slavery the
Persians were involved in yeah okay so
do you condemn that the Persian Empire
okay do you condemn the incest they used
to do they used to have incest the
Persians even in the royalty do you know
about this
huh so that's not justification is it
that's not justification okay so if
you're going to come from a moral
perspective Persia the Persian Empire
you can't speak about morality
understand they did atrocious CRI even
even even Islam there was no immorality
no there
isal killing they were killing woman one
second is there bad Muslims yes but in
Islam there is nowhere that tells you
the prophet said I forbid you from
killing women children listen listen he
said he said there is nothing in Islam
that says you are allowed to kill
innocent men women and children it's
Haram the
IGN please IGN he killed a woman in the
battlefield the prophet Muhammad said oh
Allah I am free from
what having a convers conversation you
need you need a you need a no surgery
it's too big M was
big he killed a woman in the battlefield
the prophet Muhammad said I am free
Allah from you are not allowed to kill
innocent people conquering is separate
to composion in religion otherwise okay
then okay one second the Quran says
there is no compulsion in religion right
I'm tell
why why is why is America second wait
wait one second one second one second
I'm just going to give you one
historical account when it came to the
Romans do you know the Romans controlled
Egypt firstly Roman was egpt uh Romans
colonized Egypt Romans attacked the
Muslims in the Battle of mut the Battle
of mut the Romans attacked the Muslims
the Muslims actually had three of their
commanders die in that battle is 3,000
Muslims versus a large Roman contingent
so the thing is the Romans were
aggressors now why did the Muslims
defend themselves why would you not
defend yourself you not defend never for
the first time like before they
in Islam we don't seek conflict we don't
seek to okay let's just choose a Target
and start attacking these people Islam
why you have to look at it historically
Muslims fought the Persians Muslims
fought the Romans but Muslims did not
fight the abyssinians and did not fight
the Turks and the prophet peace be upon
him said do not fight the Turks unless
they fight you do not fight the abans
unless they fight you why why because
they were not aggressors I don't know
why why so the thing is there's two
problems with what with what you're
saying the first thing is aggression if
you want to defend the Persian Empire
there's no way of Defense secondly
Muslims have the right to defend
themselves if they're attacked by other
Empires historically don't you agree
with that so what's the issue I mean
historically they let you to be free as
well so you can't say you know it's not
binary it's not zero or one you can't
say that
100% wi or you know like you can't it's
not 100% no we would say Muslim 100%
correct we would say it's 100% correct
we wouldn't say no
no
minut books
read friend